hello everyone welcome to this
session this session is about git in
case you have a chance to leave now if
this is the wrong room okay uh my name
is cidio this is going to be a pretty
technical session so hold on to your
seats and your
coffees it's called get hidden gems now
before we start I would like to ask a
few
questions how many here are uh new to
get okay one or two how many here are
intermediate git users like you use it
every day but you haven't looked into
the more advanced stuff okay so that's
most of
you and how many here are G Masters come
on I know there are a few yeah okay one
one yeah two all right okay so my goal
here today is to tell you at least one
thing that you did not know about Kit
and if for some reason you already knew
everything I told you about today then
look me up afterwards because we might
have a hobby in
common all right so what gems you might
ask well isn't it just Version Control
System well yes and no you see git is a
bit like a Swiss army knife it's a tool
that you know that is of Everyday Use
however it's also more than that it has
more features than you probably know
about and some of them are hidden Bel
below another layer that you don't
always look into and even if you find
that feature you might not know what
it's used for so yes git is kind of the
Swiss army knife of Version Control
Systems and yes I came up with this
myself in the
shower
so before we move any F further though
let me address the elephant in the room
what's with all this asky
art well you see git is a tool that was
uh created at the command line and it's
meant to be used used at the command
line now I know there are a lot of git
goys some good some bad you know they do
the job however if you want to unlock
the full power of Git You should be
using it from the command line and I'm
going to prove you why that is here
today so yes welcome to the
terminal that means that the entire
presentation is going to be from the
terminal and yes that even includes the
slides and you would will not believe
how long it took me to draw
that so let's look at it for a few more
seconds shall
we all right what's the game
plan we have a canvas we divide it into
two parts now on one side my left your
right or the other way around I never
get it right we're going to have a local
git
repository on the other side we're going
to have some text Tex and some more Ry
Graphics to explain what's going on okay
and they're going to move along together
these
two now in order to do anything we're
going to need a project now this is not
important at all but the project is a
calculator not that it matters we're
going to not look at it like from a
functional point of view but it's a
calculator and it's written in node and
it's written in typescript because why
not so that's it for the Preamble let's
start with the first gem which I call
pretty
logs
so so here we have the repository on the
left side or right side depending on
which side you're
on and you guys probably all know about
git log pretty boring command you know
it shows you the commit graph nothing
really fancy about it
however you might not know that git log
has an option called
pretty now what this allows you to do is
that it allows you to customize the
output of the history so for example if
you just wanted to see the commit
message you would pass the option pretty
and then say percent s which is a
placeholder that stands for summary
which is the first line of the commit
message and if you do this then you just
get the commit message
message now okay you might say but of
course you can do much more than that so
for example you can say l log pretty and
then you can change the color of the
output to for example red and then we
want to print a commit hash however we
don't want to look at the long commit
hash we just want the abbreviated one
which is usually six or seven
characters so let's say let's add the
percent H which stands for commit hash
now let's reset the color now let's
change the color again to yellow and now
I want to print out the any branch
reference that's currently pointing to
that commit now if you had to guess
what's the placeholder for the branch
reference b or any other
guesses are well it's neither of them
it's
D now you might wonder why on Earth is
it D well let me open a brief
parenthesis here that's because you
before in early git versions so pre
2010 you in order to print the branch
references as part of your log output
you needed to pass the dash dash
decorate option otherwise you wouldn't
see them so for historical reason the
decorate that's where the d stands for
stand for uh in order to print the
branch references so that's a bit of
history trivia for you now let's reset
the color again now let's add a space
and let's print the summary that you
already seen now let's change the color
again this time to cion let's open a
parenthesis and now I want to print the
commit timestamp however I want to print
it not as a ISO timestamp but as a time
stamp relative to now so I say author
time stamp relative to now and now let's
reset the color again and then I get
this which is much better and of course
the possibilities are
endless and I mean all you have to do to
take advantage of this is type this
string every time I mean as you can see
I got pretty fast at it no of course not
you can do better than
this you can use another feature in git
called aliases now you might or might
not know about aliases now an alias is
simply a word that you associate to a
git command together with a bunch of
options now of course we can do that for
this and this entire string so we can
create a git Alias for our pretty log
now let let me just copy this string
because we don't want to type it again
and now we say get config Global because
you want it on all repositories not just
the current one and then you say Alias
Dot and then the name of the Alias so in
this case
LG and then you say which command you
want to run when you invoke this alas
well I want to run log with the pretty
option and then I paste in the entire
string and now I can say G
LG which is what I currently I I've been
using it for years so that's my usual I
I type git LG and then when I go to a
new computer I type git LG and it says
unknown command so that's the blessing
and the curse of using aasis because you
your fingers get used to them and then
you go to a different computer we don't
don't have your aliases and then nothing
works so but you know it's really
useful let's continue on with the second
gem which is called pretty diffs to stay
in the theme of pretty things because if
you are sitting on the terminal all day
like I am you might it might it might as
well look good right doesn't have to be
black and white or green on
black so pretty divs now you all know
the diff command so let's diff the
previous commit to the latest one and
then you get this no pretty boring
everybody's seeing it
however
everything that comes out of git
commands is automatically piped through
another program called a
pager Now the default pager in git is
less which is a program that allows you
to scroll up and down using the arrows
or the J and K
Keys however it's not fixed you can
change it in with a configuration
setting and that configuration setting
is called core pager now the good thing
to know is that there are programs out
there that do pretty things with the
diff
output there are a bunch of them there
is one called def so
fancy which is you know it says it does
what it says and then there is another
one called Delta Now Delta is written in
Rust which already there tells you that
it's much cooler than the
rest so Delta is currently my pager of
choice and how do you use it well first
you need to install it which of course I
already did but it's pretty pretty easy
to do then you say git config Global
core. pager and then you say that the
pager should be
Delta and now if I run the same command
again I get this
output now what's cool about this well
you notice a few things first the plus
and minuses have been removed because
you know they're just you can see them
from the color green and red and then
you can also notice that we have syntax
highlighting for your language in the
diff which is pretty
cool so I highly recommend you to use
Delta and set it as a your
pager now let's move on
and let's start modifying files let's
talk about
staging
now it's always a good idea in git to
make commits that
are semantically cohesive what does it
mean it means that one commit should
represent one logical change for example
if you're making a refactoring that
should be one commit if you're adding a
feature that should be another commit
now as you know that's hard to do in
practice because when you're
working you might go in to implement a
new feature but then you see a
refactoring opportunity so you take it
right there and then so then how do you
split that into different commits now
with other virsion Control Systems
that's pretty hard to do if not
impossible unless you are really
disciplined with doing one thing at a
time in git it's not like like that at
all because in git you can choose your
workflow work as you like and then use
git feature to have a clean
history so one of the features that git
has for these things is called the patch
option of git ad now let's look at an
example
let's so I have a file called index.ts
which is the entry point of this
program uh now let's open it up with the
editor the only editor that you will
ever
need which is
it yes but which which text
editor did I did I hear ax no no what
did it say V oh yes thank you very much
that's the that's the editor that you
need the only editor that you'll ever
need
actually so um yeah so let's open it up
you know it's a typescript file now
let's say that I spot typo here so for
example this word over here the word
embarrassingly embarrassingly enough has
two
hours so so here is a typo so let's fix
that let's make two hours over here now
I'm in into this file and then I look at
at this feat the features of the F the
code and then I see that yes this string
here I like to change this as
well uh because I want my calculator to
be really academic so I don't want to to
say the numbers to add I want to say the
addent instead so now I made two
changes I made one change over here
which is you could say fixing a
typo and then I made another change over
here which is you could say kind of a
new feature
okay so now what I want to do is that I
want to Stage that change but I want to
leave that in my local working directory
so I want to commit just the upper
portion of of the file how do I do
that that's where the patch option comes
in so let's save
this and then I say git add patch now
what git does is that it asks me do you
want to Stage this hunk now the word
hunk here doesn't mean what you think it
means in this case it means basically in
in the unified D format which believe it
or not is a standard the word hunk means
a portion of a patch so it says do we
want to Stage this hunk and then you get
a self-explanatory list of
options which of course I mean you can
always always type the question mark and
then you get an explanation but believe
me when I say that what we want to do in
this case is we want to split this into
smaller chunks so we want to type S so
let's say split and then I get the same
question however this
time it's one of two hunks can you see
it here in the bottom
corner so do I want to Stage this and
say yes do you want to Stage this
no and then if I say get status you see
that the file is simultaneously
staged and unstaged
now you might wonder how do I look at
what I'm about to commit I want to see
the diff of what's being staged well I
can I can say gtif
staged and if I say gtif then I get what
is still in my working directory but not
to be
committed bonus tip this works also for
undoing
changes
now let's open it up
again let's say that I I am going to
type uh this is
documentation and then over here I'm
going to make a comment this is a
comment now I made two more changes I
want to undo one of the changes like
completely remove it from my working
directory but keep the other
one I can say git restore
patch and and then I get the same
question however this time it's about do
you want to discard this
hunk and then I
say split do you want to discard
this no do you want to discard this yes
do you want to discard this
no and then I'm I got rid of one of the
on the comments and then I kept the
other okay so patch works for staging
but also for undo doing portions of a
change that you have in your file pretty
useful stuff did you guys know about
this anyone knew okay couple of
you let's move
on to more staging now that we have this
situation over here where the file is
modified but only a portion of it is
about to be
committed now we have a problem because
when you commit things you not only want
them to be cohesive you also want them
to be consistent that means they should
not break the build you should be able
to confidently cherry pick a commit or
merge a branch and not having to worry
about this is going to break the build
or start failing
tests but how do you ensure that if you
are to if you are to commit only the
stage part how do you know that that by
itself doesn't break the build without
all the other changes that you still
have in your working directory so in
other words how do you isolate that well
it turns out that the stash command has
a useful option called keep
index so what this allows us to do is
that we can
stash what we have in a working
directory but we want to keep whatever
is already being
staged so now if if I say staged I still
have my change and if I say get if I
don't have anything so I got rid of
everything in my working directory and I
just kept a staged part so now I know
that that change by itself is going to
be committed and then I can for example
run the test and see that of course this
works because just know fixing a typo
but nonetheless you can verify your
changes isolated from everything
else and then this point I can make a
commit let's say fixes a
typo and then when I'm done I can say
get stash pop and get back my changes
from the
stash and here they are again okay how
many here they are using this
workflow okay couple of you cool cool
cool pretty useful thing to
know let's move on to searching now git
has some pretty powerful searching
facilities
allow you to search through the history
based on the
changes now the most powerful probably
of those search features is called
pickaxe because you imagine that you go
spelunking into your history with your
pickaxe that at least that's how I think
about
it so what option is that well you use
it with Git log of course because that's
about looking at
history and the pickaxe allows you to
look at you want to find commit that
either add or remove a line that matches
a certain pattern in other words what
commit added this code or what commit
change this
line and the option for that is uh
capital S so in this case I want to find
the commit that originally introduced
the typo okay so I say git of course you
can use you can use your alas so I can
say git LG s and then you say
embarassing with one R and then I get
two commits back of course I get the
commit that we just made that fixes the
typo and then I get another commit could
it be the one that originally introduced
it so let's grab the commit hash and
let's look at the contents a yes indeed
that was the commit that originally
introduced the
line cool stuff don't need any fancy goo
to look at to find commit based on the
contents bonus tip and this is going to
blow your mind I hope at least you blew
mine when I found out about it you can
also search by function
name what's a function well it's it's
whatever it resembles a c style function
so a name and a bunch of cbra not a
bunch two two two parenthesis and two
curly
braces doesn't matter which line they
they are if it resembles a c style
function git is going to find it and you
can find commits that somehow touch a
function so the Syntax for that is L so
you say so for example in this case I
have a file called calculator.
TS and this has an function called add
which indeed resembles a c style
function could have been CP method could
have been in Java Java method doesn't
really matter now I want to say which
commit somehow modifies this this
function and I can say gitl g l colon
the name of the function colon the path
to the file that contains that function
so calc calculator. TS
bam I get the commit that added in this
case the function and if there were
other commits that change anything
inside the function body or the
signature they will also appear here did
you know about
this kind kind of kind of new okay this
is this is pretty use one new this is
pretty useful pretty useful
stuff some so this is another point I
want to make that some goys might expose
this functionality to you but some
others don't if you're at the command
line you have the full capab ility of
everything H I'm going to prove this
point once more at least in this
presentation so let's move on to
automation questions afterwards yeah
automation all right
so there are a bunch of workflows that
are very common when you're using git
one of these workflows
is I just realized that the change I
made now should have been part of a
commit 10 commits ago has it happened to
you yes it's pretty common now this is
so common in fact that git has a
possibility that to it allows you to
make a commit and then make it part of a
previous commit you're rewriting history
you're doing something called squashing
you're squashing a commit into another
one so that it looks like it's
one and another one is called fix up
which is basically the same thing as
squash but you are not you're reusing
the commit methods you don't want to
change the commit
methods now this is so common that git
has an built-in automation feature to
make it easier to do which is called
Autos
squash now what on Earth is out to
squash well you wouldn't know because
it's off by default and why is it off by
default I don't know you tell me but you
need to enable it so you say get config
global
rebase do AOS squash you said it to true
now it's
enabled now how do you use it well let
me show
you we have H right
now A
change that this over here we change the
string the numbers to add into the
Addams now let's imagine that I would
like to squash this commit into the
commit that originally introduce the
numbers to add so that it looks like I
wrote the addent from the very beginning
okay I want to rewrite
history now first and if you haven't
noticed already I'm going to tell you
now these gems kind of build on top of
each other so as we progress we're going
to use previous tips and tricks to do
more stuff so right now we want to find
a commit that added a certain line so
we're going to use the pickaxe for
example together with our alas so we say
G LG s and then we find the string
numbers to
add there it is that's the commit that
originally added that line let's grab
the commit
hash now let's use the patch option to
partially stage the file and only stage
that change because remember we have two
changes now we don't want to Stage this
one we just want to Stage this one so we
say no and then we say
yes now we know which commit we want to
amend and we have just staged the part
we want to include so now we say get
commit D- fix up and then the hash of
the commit now what this does it creates
of course a regular commit however the
commit
message is made up to of the string fix
up exclamation mark so you can think of
it as fix
up and then you have the commit message
of the commit that is going to be
squashed
into now once you have this of course
you and then you can at this point you
could keep working with other things you
can make other
commits and that is going to be parked
for
later now what's later well later is an
interactive rebase where you want to
move that commit below the one that's
going to be squashed into
right so let's do that let let's rebase
interactive probably just
type-i and then in this case I want to
include the entire history so I say root
but in your case is probably going to
have the branch point
there
o and this
happens have you ever had this
experience you want to do a rebase but
you have changes is you know working
directory yes it
happens you might be surprised to know
that g has an automation feature for
this as
well which is also off by
default and that is called can you guess
what the name
is it's called Auto stach but please pay
attention to the spelling because it's
capital S if you type with with
lowercase s it doesn't work and you
don't know why it happened to me it has
to be stash with capital S so let's
enable it we say git config Global
rebase do aouto stash
true so now that we have enabled it
let's redo the same operation again the
rebase H something happened we're going
to look at it afterwards now what
happened here well just know that we
could do the re base even though we had
changes in our working
directory now you see this commit got
moved right below the commit that is
going to be squashed
into and the action has being changed to
fix up now imagine that you have a bunch
of those fix up commits and they with
one single rebase they are going to be
moved into the right
position so you basically do a want to
fix up commits and then you do one
single rebase and they all get they they
all move to the right position and they
all get
squashed so that's pretty pretty awesome
so in this case I don't have to do
anything but just save the file and exit
I did the rebase it got squashed we're
going to look at it but look what
happened here in the meantime it created
a stash it allowed us to do the rebase
and then it
reapplied the contents so if I look at
my working directory here is my
change if I look at my stash it's empty
no trash left left
afterwards outo
stash and outo
squash by the way let me show you our
history
now and you see that we don't have the
fix up commit
anymore and uh this
one is the one that we squashed
into if you're wondering why I typed 45
are you wondering why you're type
45 I didn't mean to I I meant to write
four which means show me the last four
commits in git log but then I slipped
and I typed five as well but that's also
good to know that you can say git log
Dash and then a number and that it shows
you just that number so for example if
you want just want to later one you can
say git log minus one
okay so let's look at this
commit uh let's look at the content and
indeed it says the addent so we have
successfully amended
it how many here knew about how to
squash and how to
stash one
okay let's move let's change gear by the
way spoiler alert I have nine gems why
do I have nine gems and not 10 because
when you're doing a presentation in the
terminal you want usually squares
because it's not easy to have round
shapes and nine looks really good on
three lines of three items that's the
reason why I have nine so dot notation
have you guys heard about the dot
notation no how about the dot dot
notation how about the dot dot dot
notation yes one in both cases dot dot
dot is a is a real thing it exists but
today we're going to look at the dot dot
notation two
dots what does it do well it allows you
to compare branches so for example let's
say that we have a situation that looks
like
this what you you have a topic branch
and you have a main branch know it's
usually your pool request Branch
whatever the question you want to ask
when you're working in a topic branch is
what commit do I have in this branch
that are not in the mainline branch and
on the other side you want to also say
what commits does a Mainline branch have
that I don't
have
so what we want to we want to basically
find
out these two commits what commits are
here that are not here so how do you
express that with the log command and
the dot dot
notation you say git log what commits
are not here but that are
here so in this case let me change to a
different
branch I have a branch called feature
ADD test script oh
let's
do I have of course changes in my
working directory that I don't want so
let me just
force okay so now we are in a topic
Branch what commits do I have here that
are not in main so I say git LG not in
main but in my current branch and then I
get this
list now the opposite is also possible
of course you want to say what commits
are in
main that are not in my topic
Branch so how do you express this of
course that is going to be the opposite
what commits are not in my topic Branch
but that are in the main
branch so basically revert that G LG not
in my feature Branch but that are in
Main and then I get those
two pretty useful stuff now it gets even
more useful it gets
useful if you combine this with the
aliases now imagine that I have an alias
called new for example that basically
says show me the commits that are in my
current Branch head the branch I've
currently checked out that are not in
master main or default or whatever you
call your main line so let's add a conf
a an alas
globally called new that basically
says LG because another thing that blew
my mind you can have aliases that
reference other
aliases can you believe it that was not
possible in git 1.0 H sorry
1.8 then in one the later versions they
added the possibility to have aliases
that reference
aliases can you can do pretty off
powerful things with that and awful
things as well you can have infinite
recursion of aliases don't don't try
that so you say main dot dot head
whatever Branch I'm currently standing
on compare that to Main and show me
what's new here then I can have another
brand another alas called missing when I
I basically say the opposite thing what
commits don't I have what commits are
not in head but that are in main are you
with me yeah so then I'm in a feature
branch and say what do I have I have
this what am I missing I have I'm
missing
those I use that all the time it's like
automatic I don't even think about it
new missing which is the problem when I
get to a new computer where I says get
new unknown command what yeah and that's
the
problem
so still you should still use those
those uh
commands
Okay now this is getting into the weed
of of git obscure
stuff rebase on two now you guys
probably know about rebase do you know
about
rebase yeah now
rebase it does what it says it changes
the base of your Branch from one commit
to another insert you all your base Meme
here so what does rebase onto then do
rebase onto allows you to take a portion
of a branch a sequence of commits not
from the branching point but somewhere
in your branch take that sequence of
commit and transport it into another
Comm it change the base of that
portion now how is that useful in might
wonder well let me show
you let's say that we have a situation
that looks like this the usual main
topic
Branch
now let's say that we have
Rewritten this commit over here which we
actually did we have amended
the second to last commit so we have
Rewritten that it becomes a new commit
with a new commit hash however any topic
branch that included that commit before
now has a reference to the old one are
you with
me yeah so that b is still present in my
current topic
Branch now what I want to do is that I
basically want
to take this two
commits and I want to move them so that
the base becomes
main thus effectively getting rid of
that so this is what I want to do and I
want to do it in one go I don't want to
fiddle around interactive rebat and
stuff I want to write one command and
take C and D which I know are the new
commits and rebase them on top of Main
and exclude B well rebase on two it's
exactly what you need for this and how
does it work the syntax is rebase on two
and then you
say what is the new
base and then that's the key part you
say what is the old base what do you
want to
replace which is different than a
regular base which basically gets all
the commits from the common parent from
the branching
point so let's try it out so we are in
the feature
branch in our case we want to say Main
and B so we want to say git
rebase onto Main right rebase it onto
the new base which is the commit
currently referenced by main what is the
old base the old B which now I realized
I forgot to grab the hash of so let's
say G
new by the way I forgot to show you that
this is indeed the case Can you spot
something when I say get new and get
missing something
interesting see here this is the
old and this is the one we amended right
still appears it's it's in main the new
one and our current feature branch is
the old one that's the one we want to
get rid of is this one so let's
grab the commit hash
and then let's say get re base onto Main
what is the old base it's
B
bam let's K it new and that commit is
gone
now
okay one operation transport a portion
of a branch into another Branch did you
guys know about
this okay one or two do you use it
regularly yeah cool because it's very
useful to also inside a branch let's say
that you want to remove some commits in
the middle of course you can do that
with an interactive rebase and then
comment them out but rebase onto is a
much faster way to do it you say what's
the new base commit that's this we which
is the old base that and everything in
between is going to be
removed okay rebase on
two of course the final result is that
we have a linear
history
now let's switch gears
again let's talk about the ref log do
you guys know about the ref
log couple of you okay so git is really
good at tracking the contents of your
files but it also tracks its own files
and in this case it tracks the branch
references so you know that in g a
branch is just a pointer to a commit now
what git does is that every time a
branch changes either you make a new
commit so you move it forward or you do
a reset you move it to somewhere else or
you do a rebase whenever a branch
changes git records the previous commit
that that Branch was pointing to into a
its own log it's called a reference log
because branches are just references
right so how do you get to the ref log
well you say ref log and then the branch
name because every branch has its own
reflog so for example I can say G reflog
Main and then I get this list where you
say that each entry here has the name of
the branch then at and then an number
which is an index which increases so the
higher the number the older the entry in
the history is and of course the latest
one is zero which is the the one we're
currently at
and you can see that also it contains
what kind of operation it is so is it
this was a rebase this was a
commit and this was a
reset now how is this useful you might
wonder oh well before we move on you
should also know oops close the
presentation never type Q when you are
doing slides from the terminal because Q
is
quit so let me just get back to this
point real
quick there you go reminder to self
don't type
Q over there but type it here so head
which is also a reference and head of
course points to the brancher currently
have checked out has it ALS also has its
own ref log which you get to by saying
get ref log without anything and this is
basically the same thing however it's
for head now what's different between a
branch ref log and heads ref log is that
remember when you change a branch when
you check out a different branch you are
changing head so the so heads reflog
also includes check out
operations and how is this useful it's a
little thing but you know you can still
use it if I switch
to I say switch but of course it's check
out switch is the new command for
that switch main I can say get switch
minus and I get back to the previous one
so you're you can thanks to the ref to
heads ref log you can switch back and
forth between two branches which is the
equivalent of saying git switch at
minus1
so the dash is basically a Syntax for
saying you see the head is implicit so
you say at minus one so the current one
minus
one okay pretty useful but how is the
ref log really useful I mean the branch
ref log
well let's say that we have a situation
that looks like
this and we have two branches topic and
Main we rebase the topic on top of Main
right which is what we actually did
right
now now let's say that we change our
mind and we want to go back to how
things were before we want to undo the
rebase however the rebase is already
complete so there is no way to abort it
it's complete it's done how do you get
back to to the previous
commit the previous commit of course is
still there but there is nothing really
pointing to
it but is there of course there is one
one thing that's pointing to it and
that's the ref log ref log remembers
what commit that Branch was pointing to
before the
rebase so how do you how do you undo a
rebase let's switch back to the feature
Branch you can always reset which is the
command to move a branch reference to a
different
commit and then you say hard because you
really mean
it now you say hard because you also
want to change your working directory so
it matches that commit that
snapshot and then you can say feature
ADD test script and if you just did the
commit if you didn't do nothing else you
know that's going to be one right which
is the previous entry so you reset that
to the previous one and if I say get new
knew now I have my old B commit back so
I effectively undid a
rebase now since we are doing so good on
time I have some bonus
tips what if you don't know where to
look in the ref log what if now there
are situations where you realize you
want to undo a rebase or undo an
operation but it's much later than you
actually
happened how do you can you can you can
you look for stuff in the ref log the
answer
yes the the the way you do that of
course you can use the pickaxe same
command that that you use to look in the
history of your commits but you can use
the same command to look in the ref log
instead so you can say git
log one line so in this case the pretty
option doesn't work with the ref log so
know that if you're going to spelunk in
the ref log you can use the cretive
option so you say log and then one line
just print one line and then you can say
s for example so the pickaxe let's look
for the commit that included the word
embarrassing with the one R however I
don't want to look in the history I want
to look in the ref log so I say walk ref
logs
instead and now I get all the entries
you see from The Ref log instead that
contain that
word now what you also want to do is
that you only if you're going to reset
your branch to something you better
reset it to either a start of rebase or
even better to a commit so when you look
in the ref log you want to find
basically
commits so what can you do well you can
take this output and pipe it to grab and
say I just want to filter commits
okay and then of if the results are long
you want to be able to scroll up and
down so you pipe it to
less and then you just get the
commits that include that word so the
embarrassing with one
R now there is another thing now of
course you just get numbers here they
might not tell you they tell you just
how old this entry is but it not might
be helpful right okay this one is much
older than this one but how do I know
which one I should reset to well another
way to make it easier is that you can
include the date instead so here I add
the date option and I say local and now
instead of the index I get the time
stamp of the
commit so this information might be it
might be easier for you to find in the
ref log that commit that include the
line that you want to get back to in
your branch and if you don't want to
reset your branch to that you can always
create a new branch that points to that
commit so something that I do for
example let me just grab one of those is
that if I find the commit that I
interested in that yes that is the one I
want to reset to I can grab the commit
hash and then I can just create a new
branch called for example temp on that
commit and now I can just look at that
commit so I create a new Branch that's
pointing in a commit that I found in the
ref
log now you might be wondering how long
are things kept around in the reflog
they're not there forever by default
they're going to be there for 90 days so
entries older than 90 days are going to
fall off the reflog and then there is
really nothing pointing to it because
the ref log is the last thing that
points to a commit and once they fall
out of the ref log they're going to be
you guessed it garbage collected because
yes git has a garbage
collector which you can invoke by saying
get GC another another little piece of
information for you but this that runs
automatically in the background so you
don't have to worry about
it
okay so what we did is in this case we
reseted to a commit that we found in the
ref log and we effectively undid AR
base all right last Gem and my favorite
one
R do you know about
r no one or right one okay I thought I
could get away
with okay so I I count it as a no then
perfect perfect okay that's always
that's my actually my favorite one R
what does it stand for can you guess now
I already to move the slide it stand for
reuse recorded
resolution makes sense so no commit uh
merge merch conflicts are the fact of
life you're not escaping them unless
you're working by yourself and even then
you can get a merged conflict with
yourself it happened to me many times s
so and have you ever been in a situation
where you have to resolve the same
conflict many times has it happened yeah
now when does this happen well one
situation where this happens is when
you're are using a kind of workflow
which is called the test merge so let's
say that you have are in a topic branch
which is long running you know you keep
this pull request alive for a long time
in the meantime the main branch is
moving
along so if you don't want to fall
behind too much which is always a good
idea to not wait too long before you
merge otherwise you're going to have all
the conflicts in the world is that you
regularly merge the main branch into
your topic Branch now bear with me not
the other way around you merge main into
your topic at regular intervals if main
is moving faster than a big team with
lot of turn you do it maybe once a
day when you do that merge you're going
to have a possibly conflict if you have
R
enabled you're going to resolve those
conflicts and G is going to remember how
you resolve them and then you keep going
with more commits and then you regularly
merge down now when you are done what
you want to do is you rebase your topic
branch on top of main now this will get
rid of all the merge commits because
rebase by default do does not preserve
merge commits so all those merges are
gone however you're going to get all the
conflicts
again but since you use the Red AR those
will be automatically resolved okay so
that is this workflow that I described
for you is very useful in situations
where you have long running topic
branches long running pool requests and
a fast moving main branch regular merge
commits so how do you use
it well the first thing you you need to
do is enable it because of course it's
off by
default and remember that of of course R
Works in recording only from the point
when you enabled it so all the conflicts
that you resolved
yesterday those are not
recorded however there is a shell script
out on GitHub that tries to train the on
Old merge conflicts but it's an um I
don't know just know that it works it
works from when you enable
it R enabled config Global re re re
enabled true all right so now it's
on now let's try we have this scenario
let's try to merge topic into main so
let's
switch back to main you see how fast it
is with the
minus as long as you're bouncing between
two Comm two branches
so let's switch to Main and let's merge
the feature
Branch
conflict yes it was
planted so uh regular conflict however
you might notice there is a new line in
the output recorded pre pre-image for
this file so Ray is active now how do
you proceed you proceed by resolving the
conflict as you normally would no no
questions there so the conflict is in
index of course it's over
here we have two two versions you could
choose just one version of course of the
other but I'm going to edit it manually
let's get rid of this let's get rid of
that actually let's get rid of
that and that so we basically want to
keep the version with the addends which
is the one we want to keep so resolve
the
conflict save and
exit so now we add this to the index we
stage it which is telling it that yes I
have resolved the conflict this version
that I've have staged is the resolved
one and then I can say get merge
continue bam now I have resolved the
conflict and notice here Rec ordered
resolution for this
file
now let's say that we change our mind
again and we want to rebase instead
instead of creating a merge committee we
want to
rebase so we are on the main branch
still let's undo the latest the latest
uh commit by resetting to the previous
one no need to use the ref log in this
case because I mean the commit is still
there so I just reset to the previous
commit before the merge
commit and now there is no
merge anymore now let's switch to
the to the topic
branch and now let's do a rebase on top
of main instead okay now of course a
rebase is still a formal merge however
instead of merging two commits you are
applying one commit one at a
time but the conflicts if they're there
you're still going to get them you're
going to get them just at when when it
comes to that
commit so of course they're going to get
the same however you see here special
line resolved using previous
resolution now you might wonder why
didn't it just do the thing why do I
have to look at it well because things
change and a resol solution that you
applied earlier might not be valid
now remember that you know these
resolutions have being recorded for long
time so G gives you the chance to look
at it and say hey I applied the solution
from earlier but does it still look
good
so in this case we just have to look at
the file and say
yes it looks like the resolution we did
earlier it's using the
addends now I might want to run some
tests to see that it didn't break
anything yes works so now how do I tell
that I want still want to keep that
resolution I just add it to the
index now what if the solution is no
longer
valid in that case I would
say G re
forget index and then it's going to
basically remove the previous resolution
for that file because the way R works is
that it remembers based on the file path
if each side of the conflict looks
exactly the same as when you resolved it
then it's going to apply the final file
that you that you used and by saying
forget you're basically removing those
files but in this case I just want to
add it and then then I say rebase
continue and I'm done okay so that's the
essence of
R let's wrap this up we have been
looking at nine gems why why nine
because they fit pretty nicely as you'll
see soon pretty logs use the pretty
option to customize the output over the
log command and then write an alas so
that you can use it
quickly pretty diffs use Delta
uh to format the output of the diff
command so that you can have syntax
highlighting and it's easier to navigate
and it's you know better on the
eyes staging we have been looking at how
to partially stage a file using the
patch option of git
ad and then we also looked at how to use
the stash keep index command to isolate
what you have staged so that you can
verify that it doesn't break the B
build we looked at searching
pickax uh- s look find commit that
either add or remove a line that matches
a pattern and by the way if you're into
regular Expressions you can say Dash
capital G instead and then you can write
a full R
exp to find the match
matches uh we look at
automation Auto
squash uh and auto stack
Autos squash allows you to speed up the
workflow where you amend the previous
commits by doing one single interactive
rebase and auto stash you can do a
rebase even though you have changes in
your working
directory the dot notation more
specifically the dot dot notation to
compare branches what's in my current
topic branch that is not in the main
line and vice versa and have aliases for
those as well
we looked at rebas onto how you
transport portion of a branch from one
branch to another instead of
transporting the entire Branch so doing
Branch surgery so to speak within
portions reased on
two we looked at the ref log gets
Universal undo
machine uh we can find commits that you
thought were lost but they're still
being referenced by the reflog and bonus
tip how to look for stuff in the ref log
using the pickaxe and the walk ref logs
option and last but not
least reuse recorded
resolutions now there is much more than
this in git as you can imagine a lot
more so if you have plural site I have a
course out called Advanced G tips and
tricks where you will find these things
and much more stuff that g has inside
its inner work that can and will improve
your daily workflow if you make them
part of your
toolbox and with that thank
[Applause]
you